stell dir vor du könntest eine art
zwilling von dir erschaffen der keine
gefühle und kein bewusstsein hat dafür
aber alle deine organe besitzt eine art
kopie von dir mit der du machen könntest
was du willst
klingt ein bisschen sehr nach dem
thriller die insel aber genau das wird
gerade zur realität auf solchen kleinen
chips hier wachsen mini organe mit denen
man allerlei simulationen durchführen
kann
neuartige arzneimittel könnten in
zukunft direkt für dich persönlich
getestet werden
das ist nicht nur viel akkurater sondern
macht auch versuche an tieren
überflüssig wie genau das funktioniert
und wann man solche chips von sich
erstellen lassen kann
das erfahrt ihr nach dem intro und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
doktor watson video und abonniert gerne
den kanal wenn ihr solche videos in
zukunft nicht verpassen wollte
das hier ist ein multi organ chip der
firma des us- aus berlin nicht viel
größer als eine packung kaugummis dieser
chip kann zweimal zwei miniaturisierte
dreidimensionale organ modelle
beherbergen und zwar hier und hier
und das ganze nochmal gespiegelt auf der
anderen seite über einen half einen
kanal auf der rückseite des chips sind
die beiden organe miteinander verbunden
dadurch fließt eine blut- ähnliche
nährstofflösung die über die anschlüsse
auf der vorderseite an eine pumpe
angeschlossen werden können
die pumpe simuliert dann dem herzschlag
der die nährstofflösung durch den
kleinen kreislauf pumpt fast genauso wie
im menschlichen körper auf diese art und
weise können die forscher heute schon
zum beispiel eine kleine mini lieber mit
einer kleine minimiere verbinden und
daran die wirkung von arzneimitteln
testen wie solche miniaturisierten
organe hergestellt werden das erklärt
mir der gründer und geschäftsführer des
startups dr uwe marx die erste
erkenntnis war dass alle und alle dass
menschen aus kleinsten
funktionseinheiten bestehen denn es geht
ja darum es zu miniaturisieren und viele
von mir oder ihnen nebeneinander auf
einem chip zu kriegen und dazu war
wichtig welche funktionseinheiten haben
unsere organe und da ist klar dass jedes
organ eine kleinste funktionseinheit hat
die zehn millimeter maßstab bewegt das
gilt für die lieber fürs gehirn für alle
organe grundsätzlich wenn man die
richtigen zählen hat und ein mikro menü
wie es in dieser funktionseinheit im
menschen ist dann es semmeln die sich zu
dieser struktur selbst haben sie eine
evolution auch gemacht das kann man sich
vorstellen wie einen kleinen haufen
zellen der 100.000 mal kleiner ist als
das originale organ und obwohl doktor
magst das so einfach klingen lässt ist
die umsetzung recht kompliziert erst
2012 wurde der medizin-nobelpreis für
eine neuartige methode vergeben die
entwicklung indizierter pluripotenter
stammzellen der weg über die stammzelle
es deutlich komplexer
aber der einzige weg alles von einem von
einem menschen auf einen job zu bekommen
und da ist es so dass er zunächst mal
über diese nobelpreis methode mit
irgendeinem gewebe wir nehmen da im
wesentlichen entweder blut oder haut
zählt die müssen sozusagen den
differenziert werden
die werden wieder richtig blöd und
müssen sie dann in umgebungen setzen die
ihr vorgaukeln du solltest eine
leberzelle werden oder eine leber
programmiert werden dass sind so kann
manchmal mehrere zellen unterschiedliche
typen in einem verbund dass das
sozusagen der jetzige weg der ist noch
sehr langwierig das ist zwar recht
aufwändig hat aber den vorteil dass man
nicht für jedes organ eines patienten
eine einzelne gewebeproben nehmen muss
das wäre auf dauer noch viel aufwendiger
über die stammzellen reicht es eine
einmalige blutprobe abzugeben aus der
dann alle möglichen verschiedenen organe
wachsen können und das sind nicht wenige
von den 34 verschiedenen organen des
menschlichen körpers können die forscher
bereits 16 simulieren
da unter den damen die niere das
pankreas und die haut die auf ein organ
ist dabei ist es sogar möglich die
verschiedenen schichten der haut akkurat
zu modellieren und auch die leber kann
auf dem chip gezüchtet werden
für die leber ist halt das organ für den
für ihren stoffwechsel schlechthin das
erste organ das was immer sie gerade zu
sich genommen haben dafür zuständig ist
das zu verarbeiten zu verstehen und
sicherzustellen dass nichts böses im
organismus landet über 500 mikrometer
sondern halben millimeter treffen diese
ganzen substanzen und diese ganzen dinge
die sie gegessen haben
nur mit leberzellen zusammen und in
diesen 500 mikrometer nur sie dadurch
schließen muss die leber entscheiden
dass es kritisch oder nicht
das ist nicht viel und deswegen sind die
leberzellen mit einer unheimlichen
leistungskraft ausgestattet ohne diesen
sozusagen rechter vor vor dem eingang
wenn manchmal so sagen davon alles muss
dadurch werden sie hatten sie noch so
ich weiß nicht fünf minuten oder sie
minuten aber fragen sie mich nicht ich
bin nicht der der intensivmediziner aber
das beschreibt eigentlich wie schnell
sie sich vergiften wenn es nicht da
wären die komplexität der organe so
präzise wie möglich darzustellen ist
schwierig aber wichtig denn je mehr man
mit den chips dem vorbild des
menschlichen organismus kommt desto
genauere aussagen kann man über die
auswirkungen von arzneimitteln treffen
schon heute können zwei und sogar vier
verschiedenen organe auf den chip
simuliert und miteinander verbunden
werden
das große ziel der forscher ist aber der
chips ein schiff auf dem über zehn
verschiedene organe des menschen
miteinander verbunden sind
die meisten experten sind sich einig
dass man mindestens diese anzahl an
organen erreichen muss um ein gutes
physiologisches modell eines menschen
darzustellen
unsere eigentliche vision ist den ganzen
menschen darzustellen dann könnten wir
die klinische phase 2 nach auf den chips
dann braucht es auch keine gesunden
versuchspersonen vorher mehr und dann
würde dramatisch an menschlichen
testpersonen sparen und die tiere
komplett ersetzen können
schon heute gibt es dank der multi organ
chips weniger tierversuche denn die
chips mit zwei und vier organen werden
von pharma und kosmetik konzernen für
tests genutzt obwohl laborratten uns in
vielerlei hinsicht erstaunlich ähnlich
sind sind sie doch offensichtlich keine
menschen
so gibt es zum beispiel wirkstoffe wie
laborratten nicht beeinflussen die aber
für uns menschen toxisch sind
vier von fünf arzneimittelkandidaten
werden an tieren erst erfolgreich
getestet um dann an klinischen studien
am menschen zu scheitern
all diese arzneimittel sollen von den
chips schon vorher aussortiert werden
bevor auch nur ein tier das medikament
erhalten muss die krankheiten die mit
den chips heute schon untersucht werden
sind die bei denen der grösste
forschungsbedarf besteht
diabetes typ zwei alzheimer und krebs
für die arzneimittelentwicklung ist eben
sich wichtig zu verstehen bevor man den
menschen geht welche dosis kann man
einsetzen und hier hat mir jetzt ein
modell
können wir das sogenannte therapeutische
fenster raus bekommen wie hoch kann ich
mit der dosis gehen damit ich schon eine
gute wirkung am tumor habe aber hier
noch keine nebenwirkungen die
katastrophal für den patienten endet das
spannende daran ist dass der chip den
gesamten menschlichen organismus
physiologisch abbilden soll
ein wirkstoff wird also über die wand
des miniatur darms in das chip system
gegeben denn ein mensch würde eine
tablette ja auch einfach schlucken
von da aus gelangt der wirkstoff dann
über die nährstoff lösung zur leber und
wenn er dort nicht als giftig eingestuft
wird nach und nach zu allen anderen
organen die auswirkungen des wirkstoffs
können dann für jedes organ einzeln
überprüft werden und das ganze
funktioniert für jeden patienten
individuell in der vision der forscher
hat in der zukunft jeder patient seinen
eigenen individuellen biochip aus seinem
blut mit seinem immunsystem und den
organen entstanden aus seinen
stammzellen jedes medikament und jede
kombination aus medikamenten kann so
erstmal ohne risiken auf dem chip
simuliert werden
das ist personalisierte medizin
ok an dieser stelle muss ich sagen dass
ich echt großen respekt vor diesem start
up aber tierversuche reduzieren
krankheiten bekämpfen um das alles auf
einem chip der super günstig ist und
tendenziell allen menschen
bereitgestellt werden kann
da fragt man sich natürlich wo ist der
haken wahrscheinlich haben sich viele
von euch schon gefragt wo das ganze
hinführt menschen auf einem chip ich
habe nicht ohne grund im intro die insel
erwähnt im film werden achtung spoiler
menschen geklont damit man sie als
organspender nutzen kann er das
tropische aussichten aber ich wurde
beruhigt die ethischen grundsätze waren
von anfang an klar
die chips dürfen keine empathie
empfinden kein bewusstsein haben
deswegen mag dr marx den begriff human
ohne chip auch überhaupt nicht er
bevorzugt jupiter university ou logical
template also generelle physiologische
schablone bleibt mir nur noch die
gemeinste aller fragen zu stellen
ab wann können wir mit dieser
technologie rechnen ich denke wir müssen
trennen in einen wenn es jetzt ein
physiologisches template was gesund ist
da glaube ich sind wir bei uns in zwei
drei jahren mit fertig und danach muss
man krank machen also dieses
krankheitsmodellen da draußen einen
alzheimer-krankheit modell zu machen auf
einem gesunden chip oder an diabetes
oder einen tatsächlich wachsenden tumor
mit bestimmter das braucht vielleicht
noch mal ein paar jahre
ein unglaublich spannendes thema mit
ganz vielen einzelheiten ich habe jetzt
nicht über alles sprechen können
allerdings erst mal vielen dank an die
leute vom tisch und sie haben drehen
lassen
wenn ihr fragen habt weil das ja
wirklich ein sehr komplexes thema ist
dann könnt ihr gerne unten in den
kommentaren stellen und das expertenteam
vom tisch es wird uns helfen die
kommentare zu beantworten wenn ihr
irgendwelche sehr speziellen fragen habt
jetzt - in den ersten tagen nach ablauf
des videos könnt ihr auf jeden fall
alles hier loswerden und die fragen
werden beantwortet
eine frage habe ich auch noch an euch
würdet ihr euch auch so einen chip
bringen lassen würde ihr einen jungen
ohne chip mit euch machen lassen
schreiben das gerne mal unten in die
kommentare ansonsten vielen dank an das
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung für die unterstützung bei
diesem video an euch vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und immer bis zum nächsten mal
bleibt neugierig
[Musik]